soyez juste un peu un
peu plus réfléchi un peu plus
gentil parce que vous ne savez vraiment pas
ce que
quelqu'un traverse,
je pense que c'est une partie humaine tellement cruciale
de ce qui nous manque parfois, c'est juste une
compréhension de base de  d'autres êtres humains et
leur vie et ce que cela doit
signifier de vivre une autre vie qui n'est pas
la vôtre peut-être que c'est pourquoi nous faisons des
films pour que vous puissiez voir la
situation du regard de quelqu'un d'autre et
avoir de l'
empathie et de la compréhension pour les personnages
peut-être que vous le feriez
Je ne l'ai pas eu avant, je pense que c'est comme la
beauté de la narration à bien des égards,
je pense que si souvent nous voyons surtout dans les
films de super-héros, nous voyons ces images du
personnage féminin de soutien comme une sorte
d'impuissance
alors comment avez-vous essayé de défier  ce
spectacle bien, je pense que ce qui était vraiment
spécial, c'est que John a
toujours eu cela à l'esprit, je n'ai jamais vraiment
eu à m'en soucier parce que je savais
que John ne laisserait pas cela se produire,
il ne te laisserait
pas  sais que rmj est juste devenu
comme la demoiselle ou quoi que ce soit, euh,
elle a toujours eu sa propre agence
et avait ses propres opinions, pensées
et idées et
souvent très euh cruciale pour essayer
non seulement de faire avancer l'intrigue, mais de bouger euh
euh mais en fait comme avoir  quelque chose à
voir avec une solution qu'est-ce que ça fait
d'incarner un personnage aussi emblématique euh euh
assez spécial je pense
euh je pense que l'accueil n'a pas toujours
été chaleureux euh
pour plein de raisons différentes mais euh de
quelle manière
écoute il y a il n'y a pas  vous savez toujours que
tout le monde n'est pas content quand il
y a un changement de personnage,
surtout quand ils ont leur propre
vision de ce à quoi ils devraient ressembler, mais
je n'ai
que du soutien de ce côté
et je pense  la
chose écrasante a été positive je me suis
beaucoup amusé
avec le personnage et
je me sens très chanceux de pouvoir jouer notre
version notre interprétation de mj et qui
elle est et qui elle représente
dans um
dans ce monde moderne
je le ferais  je dis que mes sheroes sont les femmes de
ma famille mes sœurs aînées
euh
ma mère mes grands
-mères même mes petites nièces
euh
je pense qu'elles m'apprennent toutes tellement juste
par la façon dont elles vivent leur vie et comment elles
existent dans le monde même
tu sais  ils ne savent même pas vraiment l'
impact qu'ils ont sur moi, je pense euh,
mais aussi même les
erreurs qu'ils commettent, vous savez que c'est normal de
faire des erreurs, soyez humain, il s'agit de la façon dont
vous apprenez d'eux et grandissez avec eux,
donc j'ai appris un  beaucoup des
femmes de ma vie